[Musique]
la société de consommation n'aura pas
épargné les soucis au petit épicier de
quartier il a vu naître les grands
magasins se développer les hypermarchés
et aujourd'hui il essuie une nouvelle
forme de concurrence l'ouverture de plus
en plus tardives l'ouverture la nuit les
dimanches et jours fériés de certaines
grosses entreprises dans cette course à
la consommation un grand magasin de
nancy vient de lancer une expérience
ouverture 24 heures sur 24 formule
non-stop à l'américaine la seule
actuellement en france il sera bien
entendu à l'hostilité des commerçants
d'anciens qui ne peuvent soutenir la
concurrence personnel dans nos magasins
qui est essentiellement féminin à
travailler le soir très tardivement
alors que la plupart mère de famille
habite à l'extérieur de nancy et qu'en
conséquence il est certain que cela pose
des problèmes sur le corps humain et
social et que sur ce plan si nous sommes
contre ralliant dans cette opinion
l'ensemble du centrale ouvrière c'est
parce que nous estimons que l'on
reviendrait 20 en arrière en ce qui
concerne le progrès social auquel tout
le monde a ce sont donc surtout les
syndicats qui sont hostiles
les syndicats sont aussi le sommes
entièrement d'accord avec vous mais ya
également le problème des travailleurs
indépendants c'est-à-dire des
commerçants que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter le petit commerçant lui le
petit table pro d'amazon le petit
boulanger le petit boulanger lui est ce
qui peut ouvrir 24 heures sur 24 il est
forcé d'avoir quelques heures de repos
il est forcé de prendre son repos avec
son épouse par conséquent l'égalité des
chances que nous réclamons n'est pas en
réalité exemple puisque automatiquement
pendant des heures de fermeture la
grande surface
elle sera ouverte
et par conséquence plus fera absolument
et loyal en attendant le magasin
poursuit son expérience et même la nuit
il ya des clients beaucoup plus qu'on
imagine d'ailleurs avec l' ouverture
non-stop le chiffre d'affaires des
caisses a doublé mais dans ce genre
d'entreprise
il n'y a qu'une place à prendre dans une
ville de province
car l'éventail de clientèle nocturne
demeure restreint de la viande à 1h30 du
matin journée on ressort du bal il côté
je viens de faire un magie basket pas
m'acheter un challenge sportif alors je
termine très tard parce qu'on a faim on
est en train de faire la fête on a passé
à bois je travaille de nuit je termine
pour qu'à 1h30 du matin est beaucoup
plus facile pour moi de faire des
commissions cette période on peut donc
éprouvé le besoin d'acheter un bifteck
ou une boîte de conserve à 2 heures du
matin reste encore à savoir si c'est le
besoin qui entraîne la consommation ou
si c'est la consommation intel
consommateurs
les groupements de consommateurs ont
leur idée sur la question qui n'est pas
la même que celle des fabricants mais
les plus hostiles encore à l'expérience
non-stop comme à toute prolongation
d'ouverture sont les syndicats de
personnels qui voit une dégradation des
conditions de travail
là où attention estime qu'il y a service
rendu nous pensons qu'il n'y a aucune
raison qu'il n'y ait pas un magasin
d'alimentation qui offre en permanence
un service de garde
de la même manière qu'il y à des
pharmacies de garde ou même des stations
service et quelle peut être la clientèle
de nuit en général et à la clientèle de
nuit est exactement semblable à la
clientèle belge
à ceci près néanmoins que le pourcentage
des clients appartenant à la classe
laborieuse et plus important la nuit
[Musique]